[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité des sarcophages du
Moyen-Âge en plein centre-ville c'est la
découverte surprenante réalisée il y a
quelques jours à Bordeaux la rédaction
de TV7 la chaîne du groupe sud-ouest
nous en dire à un peu plus sur les
fouilles actuelles
quel est le meilleur cassoulet du monde
vaste question et bien la question très
sérieuse fait l'objet d'un championnat
du monde organisé à Toulouse justement
les caméras de vie à Occitanie nous
raconterons les coulisses de cet
événement à pétissant et puis top départ
pour les vacances d'hiver avec l'arrivée
de la neige Vosges TV nous emmènera en
balade en raquette de très belles images
et du bonheur en fin de l'édition
maison débute donc ce journal avec cette
découverte historique réalisée en plein
centre-ville à Bordeaux une nécropole
datant du Moyen-Âge vient d'être mise au
jour par une équipe d'archéologues 35
sarcophages révélées sous la voirie dans
le cadre d'un chantier et qui devrait
permettre d'en savoir un peu plus sur le
passé médiéval de la cité bordelaise
reportage et explication d'Alix Fourcade
pour TV7 la chaîne du groupe sud-ouest
en plein centre ville de Bordeaux en
face de l'église Saint-Seurin Justine
travaille sur un sarcophage elle dégage
les os d'un squelette qui date du
Moyen-Âge il est plutôt en bon état
en forme plus vraiment mais plutôt en
bon état en tout cas
ça se tient quand même plutôt pas mal et
on a tous les eaux qui sont dedans donc
c'est déjà c'est déjà bien en tout 35
sarcophages ont été mis au jour ce qui
représente une soixantaine d'individus
dans cette ancienne nécropole au-dessus
de laquelle doit passer la nouvelle
ligne du bus express pour relier la gare
Saint-Jean à Saint-Aubin-de-Médoc d'ici
le printemps 2024 ces fouilles
préventives ne cessent d'attirer les
regards des passants
et c'est impressionnant ce n’est en
réalité pas la première fois qu'une
telle découverte a lieu dans la
métropole bordelaise en octobre dernier
déjà 660 sépultures ont été mises au
jour en plein centre-ville de
Saint-Médard-en-Jalles cette nouvelle
étape nous éclaire sur la taille de
Bordeaux à l'époque ici il y a une
occupation sur à peu près 1000 ans entre
le sixième huitième siècle jusqu'à
jusqu'au 18e siècle à peu près un autre
élément intéressant a été découvert lors
de ses fouilles le sol d'un bâtiment
dont l'utilité n'a pas encore été
identifié et qui remontrait à
l'Antiquité tardive toutes les pièces
collectées vont ensuite être analysées
dans les locaux du centre d'archéologie
préventive de la métropole ce qui nous
permettra d'en apprendre plus sur le
mode de vie et la santé des pores de
lait de l'époque
leur travail est essentiel et permet à
l'hôpital de tenir tous les jours trois
ans après la crise covid la rédaction de
LM TV Sarthe a suivi le quotidien des
agents de bionettoyage de l'hôpital du
Mans ces femmes et ces hommes ont la
lourde mission chaque jour de
désinfecter les chambres pour éviter la
transmission des maladies un travail
méconnu mais qui regroupe néanmoins des
savoir-faire spécifique reportage d'Enzo
Maubert
merci à tout à l'heure Sandra fait
partie des petites mains de l'hôpital
depuis 21 ans elle est agent de
bionettoyage à la maternité 21 ans
qu'elle répète le même rituel plusieurs
fois par jour des infection des mains
toujours après je mets mes gants à
chaque service de chaque bâtiment de
l'hôpital
c'est automatique sandra est chargé de
nettoyer mais surtout de désinfecter les
chambres avec des procédures très
strictes
en premier et puis en deuxième temps
c'est la salle de bain 45 minutes par
chambre en moyenne le métier demande
organisation minutie chaque meuble
chaque poignet sont scrupuleusement
nettoyés rien ne doit être oublié les
risques de contamination sont
omniprésents patient qui serait dans une
chambre covid et avec plus loin un
patient qui ne serait pas covid le
risque serait de transporter d'une
chambre à l'autre le germe bonjour
madame je viens de nettoyer la comme je
peux allumer ma lumière a choisi le
métier pour le contact avec les enfants
et les mamans qu'elle croise au
quotidien mais parfois elle aimerait que
son travail soit mieux connu et reconnu
et savoir ce qu'on fait enfin c'est
important on a besoin de nous quoi et
j'espère encore dans l'avenir on a
encore besoin de nous parce que on est
quand même les premières personnes à
gérer l'ensemble de l'hôpital un maillon
essentiel de la chaîne pourtant
aujourd'hui en manque de bras c'est un
métier qui est qu'on peut qualifier je
pense sans tension puisque effectivement
c'est un métier qui est physique qui est
difficile pour lequel du coup on a aussi
des arrêts des gens qui subissent aussi
la fatigue inévitablement l'hôpital du
Mans compte 150 agents de bio nettoyage
dans ces différents services toutes et
tous sont formés à ce métier particulier
qui œuvre dans l'ombre des soignants
voilà et l'attention portée aux autres
passe également par le bénévolat en
plein hiver et alors que les
températures sont souvent négatives la
nuit les associations sont mobilisées
pour venir en aide au plus fragile
distribution de vêtements chauds de
nourriture ou quelques mots de réconfort
la rédaction de 8 Mont-Blanc a suivi une
Marau d'organiser par l'Ordre de Malte
reportage signé Manon Touati regardez
[Musique]
ça apporte un petit soutien moral quand
même parce que ce qu'ils font bon bah
c'est très utile je le cacherai pas ça
réchauffe l'estomac ça réchauffait un
peu le cœur les points de rencontre vont
se multiplier dans la soirée il peut y
avoir jusqu'à 80 personnes sans domicile
qui viennent à la rencontre des
bénévoles des personnes isolées des
couples voire même parfois des familles
à quoi tu vas
les bénévoles sont devenus des points de
repères pour eux ils sont parfois le
seul interlocuteur de leur journée ils
ont besoin d'avoir cette relation là ils
ont besoin de voir des personnes on va
aussi pouvoir les guider vers d'autres
associations qui existent les orientés
vers les services sociaux Élodie
Rodolphe et Claudine vont encore tourner
longtemps avant de pouvoir rentrer chez
eux ils finiront la marotte entre 23
heures et une heure du matin
comment parler de sécurité routière à
des adolescents si la mission semble
impossible elle vient pourtant d’être
relevée avec succès par un lycée du
Maine-et-Loire pour sensibiliser les
plus jeunes au port de la ceinture un
simulateur de retournement de bus à prix
place au sein de la cour de
l'établissement un moyen d'alerte ces
futurs conducteurs avec une mise en
situation à 90 degrés reportage de
Pierre jeunes vrais pour TLC la
télévision locale de Cholet
qu'une vingtaine de secondes au quart
sur vérin pour changer de position
inutile de dire que basculer de 90
degrés sur la gauche et plutôt
inconfortable mais l'animation
retranscrit bien ce que peut être un
accident de la route et malheureusement
ce qui tue le plus dans ce cas là c'est
le fait de ne pas avoir sa ceinture
d'être éjectée à l'extérieur de l'engin
et de subir des dommages dramatiques
c'est pour cela que les outils de
prévention comme celui-ci existent c'est
un car monté sur un semi-remorque qui
est la particularité de simuler un
accident de circulation donc oui il
viendrait à se renverser sur son flanc
gauche l'idée c'est de faire vivre au
passager de l'Intérieur l'accident pour
qui puisse avoir une idée de ce qui
pourrait se passer donc on parle un peu
de l'évacuation mais surtout en apporte
une importance toute particulière sur le
port de la ceinture de sécurité depuis
septembre 2022 5 accidents de Caron déjà
été enregistrés pour le coup il n'y a
même pas eu de blessés mais le risque
est toujours là de par leur hauteur et
leur centre de gravité des 40 ans ça se
renverser en cas d'accident en tout cas
plus rapidement qu'une voiture commune
on a certes un peu moins d'accidents
qu'en 2021 mais pour autant on a des
amortissements qui sont plus graves et
qui créent davantage de de victimes de
victimes graves et surtout de décès en
2022 et malheureusement le bilan est
encore provisoire nous avons enregistré
36 morts dans le dans le dans le
département c'est 10 de plus qu'en 2021
et c'est évidemment
nettement trop au regard des progrès qui
ont été fait ces dernières années
voilà on ne le répétera jamais assez
attaché votre ceinture en voiture ou à
bord d'un quart du lycée à l'école
primaire direction le Lot-et-Garonne
dans ce journal département dans lequel
a grandi le dernier prix Nobel de
physique à l'un aspect ce spécialiste de
physique quantique s'est rendu il y a
quelques jours dans l'école de son
enfance le temps d'une visite comme vous
le voyez sur ces images de nos
partenaires de la Dépêche du Midi
accompagné de Francis Cabrel le chanteur
l'autre star local le chercheur s'est
replonger dans ses souvenirs des
colliers et familiaux propos recueillis
par Clément Gassi
bien sûr c'est une grande émotion de me
retrouver ici parce que c'est une école
ou non seulement j'ai été en classe mais
j'ai vécu dans cette maison ici mes
parents étaient instituteurs ici ils
auraient été tellement fiers de voir ce
qui se passe actuellement donc je ne
peux pas ne pas penser à eux j'ai appris
à lire à écrire ici avec la mère d'Alain
et donc l'histoire continue de façon on
ne peut plus magnifique puisque le fils
reçoit le prix Nobel si tu veux j'ai
appris avec la mère du prix Nobel de
physique
sans transition dans ce journal
l'intérêtons-nous à présent à cette
étude menée en Martinique pour
comprendre l'impact de la pêche de
loisirs sur l'île plus de 25000
personnes pratiquent cette activité et
c'est pour mieux cerner ces
répercussions écologiques et économiques
que des travaux ont été menés auprès de
125 pêcheurs antillais précision de
Marlène mec pour via TV Martinique sur
place
dernier préparatif pour Édouard et son
fils montage des cannes à pêche
vérification du moulinet choix des
leurres si je pars à la pêche sans ça
c'est parti direction le bord de mer se
coin du Cap Macré et l'un des endroits
favoris des lois depuis 12 ans il pêche
ici sa technique le long s'est ramené et
parfois au bout de la ligne une belle
prise sarde à que jeûne Barracuda tazar
poids taille date pendant une année il a
répertorié chaque prise dans le cadre de
l'étude sur la pêche de loisirs menée
par l'Ifremer avec 124 autres pécheurs
un suivi qui lui a permis de prendre
conscience de la ressource je tiens un
poisson qui n'est pas plus grand que ma
mère en fait je relâche ce poisson comme
Édouard et son fils ils sont plus de
25000 à pêcher pour le plaisir en
Martinique soit 7% de la population
c'est deux fois plus que la moyenne
nationale chaque année il pêche plus de
550 tonnes de poissons et crustacés une
prise sur 5 est relâchée donc c'est une
valeur très importante puisque cela
représente environ 20% des débarquements
totaux en produits de la mer et la
moyenne mondiale elle s'élève environ
12%. donc on est bien au-delà de de
cette moyenne mondiale les résultats de
l'étude menés par les frères confirme
qu'il faut poursuivre ce suivi de la
pêche de loisirs d'autant plus que la
réglementation qui s'applique au pêcheur
est souvent méconnue
voilà qui t'ont les rives de la
Martinique pour la Bretagne dans ce
journal elle a découvert cette fois-ci
d'un chantier participatif et solidaire
pour l'extension de sa médiathèque une
commune d'îles et vilaines a décidé de
faire appel à la bonne volonté de ses
habitants qui ont dû mettre la main à la
patte entourée par des chefs de chantier
ces bénévoles peuvent ainsi se former un
échange de services que nous raconte
claire-grio journaliste pour la
rédaction de TVA à Rennes est-ce qu'il y
en a un de chaque équipe qui peut venir
on va faire juste une petite chaîne de
5,6 pour amener des Adobe au milieu ces
Adobe sont des briques en terre crues un
mélange de terre et de paille elles ont
été façonnées à la main il y a plusieurs
mois par les habitants ou voisins de
Bazouges-la-Pérouse et servent à la
construction de la future extension de
la médiathèque un chantier participatif
d'une quinzaine de bénévoles encadrés
par cet artisan maçon ils l'ont appliqué
d'abord le mortier ensuite tremper les
Adobe pour que le lion peut se faire
assembler ce qu'on appelle ourdet ou
maçonné respire les joints pendant 5
semaines 7800 briques comme celle-ci
vont être assemblées dans ce projet
éco-conçu avec une ossature en douglas
une essence de bois locale et une
isolation en laine de bois et de chanvre
des matériaux locaux et simples pour se
bâtiment qui a vocation à accueillir de
la petite enfance
naturel de la chaleur et l'humidité dans
un bâtiment et qui va voir apporter du
confort sur le bâtiment et sans pour
autant avoir des grosses machines des
bécanes électriques ou de l'argent on
est vraiment sur la cachette de naturel
et de deconomes pour cette première des
quatre sessions ouvertes bénévoles ils
étaient 15 à mettre la main à la pâte
comme ce père de famille venu avec ses
deux enfants il participait à la
construction de du lieu dans lequel on
aura plaisir à lire des livres c'est
quand même plutôt chouette l'extension
de la médiathèque de Bazouges-la-Pérouse
devrait t'ouvrir en septembre 2023
alors là on est sur le pupitre de
locomotive CC 72000 la restaurée et on
l'a équipé de commande avec un système
qu'on appelle l'Arduino afin d'en faire
un simulateur avec le jeu train
simulateur depuis l'âge de 3 ans Quentin
et fan du monde ferroviaire aujourd'hui
président de l'association ASL 26 il
récupère et restaure de nombreuses
pièces principalement des nez de
locomotive et des pupitres ça va de la
simple casquette des années 80 au poste
de locomotive des pupitres au siège
corail et aux plaques émaillées que la
SNCF autrefois possédaient il y a peu de
temps de nouvelles pièces ont rejoint la
collection notamment un nez de
locomotive qui devrait être transformé
en barre ça c'est un Héli locomotive de
la série des bébés 7200 et ce qui a
permis du coup d'anticiper un nouveau
projet c'était de pouvoir en faire un
bar pour le présenter en exposition des
projets Quentin en a plein la tête dont
celui de recréer un espace corail dans
le futur musée objectif faire voyager
les visiteurs le siège unique violet
comme ceci c'est un siège des corail
Rhône-Alpes donc qui ont pas mal disparu
à l'heure d'aujourd'hui c'est vrai que
le confort corail aujourd'hui c'est l'un
des plus appréciés du monde entier ça
permet de retracer l'endroit où les
corail ont roulé le rouge par exemple
c'était pour la Bourgogne le bleu
c'était pour le Franche-Comté ou le
Rhône-Alpes l'association est porteuse
de deux gros projets le Vélorail entre
jeuny et au son et le musée le but
mettre en valeur le patrimoine
ferroviaire au bois de nouvelles pièces
vont être reçues dont un nez de
locomotive qui deviendra lui aussi un
bar et un pupitre qui pourra rejoindre
la famille des simulateurs
voilà une belle histoire faite d'amour
et de passion pour les trains qui nous
transportent maintenant à la découverte
ou plutôt à la redécouverte d'une
gourmandise des Hauts de France la
ficelle picarde en cette période de la
Chandeleur vous êtes nombreux à vous
faire plaisir alors de passer à table
mais alors quel est le secret d'une
bonne ficelle picarde la rédaction de
Wii OTV nous en dévoile quelques
ingrédients avec deux versions une
traditionnelle et une revisitée à vous
de choisir un reportage de Jérémie
Houbron sur place
et voici la vraie pucelle picarde elle
s'invite régulièrement à la table de
toupie car qui se respecte plus qu'un
plat la ficelle picarde est un identité
culinaire farouchement défendue
[Musique]
l'habitude de manger quand on était
jeune bon c'est ça c'est convivial c'est
facile à réaliser
vous agréable quoi dans cette boucherie
sont vendus chaque jour une quarantaine
de ces crêpes roulées dont la
composition ne laisse pas la place au
débat la base la crêpe après les
champignons et puis après donc
incorporer avec la tranche de jambon à
l'intérieur rouler crème fraîche gruyère
râpée ah non du tout non non justement
c'est une très bonne jambon là ouais
ficelle picarde c'est 100 béchamel c'est
un mien dans les années 50 que la
ficelle picarde aurait vu le jour avec
une recette inchangée depuis des
décennies il y a quelques semaines
Julien entrait dans la liste de ses
chefs qui ont osé revisiter la ficelle
picarde et quand on s'attaque à un
monument du terroir Picard mieux vaut en
respecter les codes revisiter un plat
c'est garder quand même les saveurs qui
constituent la recette on va vraiment
retravailler toutes les textures et les
saveurs mais par contre on va s'y
retrouver quand même crème de jambon et
spuma de fromage les textures sont
différentes pourtant les marqueurs de la
recette originale sont bien là jusqu'à
la fameuse duxelle de champignons taillé
au couteau s'il vous plaît ici la crêpe
traditionnelle devient tuile de galette
au sarrasin une crêpe traditionnelle si
on la met à sécher elle va réduire son
volume énormément on utilise une galette
de sarrasin ou de blé noir des galettes
qui vont beaucoup moins réduire au
séchage et qu'on va pouvoir garder dans
une forme
qu'on souhaite en quelques minutes un
plat Parti populaire arrive haute
couture la preuve que la tradition peut
bien laisser place à un peu de folie
pourvu qu'elle reste gourmande
des trésors culinaires elles n'ont plus
n'en manquent pas en région
Occitanie la star des fourneaux c'est
évidemment le cassoulet ce plat typique
dispose même de son propre championnat
du monde organisé il y a quelques jours
à Toulouse évidemment la direction du
chef Michel serrant celui-ci s'est
déroulé sous le palais de 150 invités un
concours fait de traditions et de bonnes
odeurs comme vous allez le voir avec ce
sujet de Lisa Hervé pour via Occitanie
préparatif pour Romains il ouvre les
festivités de ce championnat du monde du
cassoulet de Toulouse pour cette finale
5 restaurateurs présentent tour à tour
leur recette et c'est bien pour les
goûter que Jean-Marc prend part pour la
troisième fois à cet événement
identiques et c'est tout l'intérêt c'est
qu'on peut en manger par exemple 5 ce
soir et avoir cinq plats quasiment
différents comme lui plus de 150
personnes participent à cette grande
dégustation à l'aveugle
qu'il soit de Castelnaudary de
Carcassonne ou de Toulouse le cassoulet
fait la fierté des habitants d'Occitanie
plats typiques et régionaux après les
amateurs c'est au tour des
professionnels de livrer leur top
commentaires il y a pas les marquants du
cassoulet j'aime bien voir le config
j'ai voulu voir la saucisse de Toulouse
la saucisse comme on a pu avoir sur
l'autre là on a des morceaux une fois
les cassoulets savourer jury et public
vote après délibération
restaurant Le gentiment
[Applaudissements]
romain et Priscilla remportent les prix
du jury et du public certains avaient
beaucoup trop de haricots d'autres au
contraire trop de viande la chouette
équilibre parfait ça nous fait
extrêmement plaisir on a le gentiment
d'avoir une vraie reconnaissance et pas
que sur le cassoulet sur ces 20
dernières années de métier et puis
cerise sur le gâteau le meilleur
cassoulet 2023 voyagea jusqu'au Japon en
fin d'année pour y être dégusté
voilà et après un bon cassoulet que
diriez-vous de faire un peu d'activité
physique à la montagne il n'y a pas que
le ski ou le snowboard qui attire les
visiteurs et les locaux avec le retour
de la neige les activités ne manquent
pas exemple avec une famille qui a fait
appel au service d'un accompagnateur en
montagne pour s'offrir une belle balade
en raquette un sujet enneigé signé
Thierry Lasson et Anne Didier pour vous
jeter les
ça juste pile poil à votre à votre
chaussure rendez-vous avait été fixé au
col de grosse pierre entre Gérardmer La
Bresse pour une petite séance raquette
une sortie en famille sous la conduite
d'un accompagnateur en montagne allez
c'est parti hélas dans la brume pour de
bonnes heures de balades conviviales
avec au préalable quelques petites
recommandations d'usage pour marcher
avec des raquettes vous avez vu le talon
il se lève derrière ça permet de marcher
normalement l'inconvénient c'est qu'il
faut éviter de faire des démarches
arrières sinon ça va se planter de la
neige première fois en raquette c'est
compliqué pour l'instant ça va
accompagnateur en montagne un métier
passion et quatre saisons raquette VTT
randonnée à pied gyropode ou sortie
chamois il y en a pour tous les goûts et
tous les publics c'est adapté d'un point
de vue physique soit facile ou difficile
selon ce que les gens recherchent et
puis adapté aussi dans en fonction de ce
que les gens souhaitent voir est-ce
qu'on a plutôt envie d'avoir des balades
en forêt avoir des points de vue
voilà les vacances d'hiver qui débutent
donc ces jours-ci et quelques jours de
congés qui vous permettront peut-être de
découvrir de nouveaux paysages dans la
Loire il est notamment possible de se
balader en chien de traineau à travers
le massif du Pilat une expérience vous
allez le voir faites de vitesse et de
cohésion entre l'homme et les animaux de
belles images dans son reportage de
Marylise Pariot pour TL7
est-ce que c'est bon pour vous c'est bon
vous avez une bonne assurance vie non je
rigole
voilà comment démarre une promenade de
chien de traîneaux la vitesse de pointe
atteint les 30 km/h et les 10 chiens qui
tirent le traîneau sont bien aidés par
le musher il indique d'une voix douce
mais Claire les ordres chiens monsieur
allez
c'est bien la meute est solidaire est
complémentaire elle se compose pourtant
de 4 races différentes husky Alaskan
malamute et esquimau du Groenland ce
chien ils vont rester complices tout au
long de leur vie parce que même les
parents ou les chiots que ça soit au
travail en remarquera que c'est toujours
des groupes qui restent formés ensemble
soudés entre les petits et les parents
même le mal prend ce rôle de père très
au sérieux chez le chien de traîneau et
derrière à la maison quand ils seront
dans les enclos chez nous c'est des
parcs où les chiens sont tous ensemble
donc les 25 composants notre mode sont
tous ensemble en liberté dans l'enclos
et le soir ils se mettent par box par
affinité et en fait on a tendance à les
retrouver tous dans la niche le
lendemain matin quand il a fait un peu
froid en boule mais les uns contre les
autres l'activité de chien de traîneaux
est possible sous réservation les
clients suivants avaient profité de Noël
pour offrir cette expérience on voulait
impérativement le faire sur la neige pas
sur le
pas sur le chariot vous voulez vraiment
le faire sur le traîneau le paysage est
magnifique mais si vous êtes dans le
coin n'oubliez pas de tenir en laisse
votre propre chien ceci ont très envie
de jouer
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
merci d'avoir suivi le grand JT des
territoires on se retrouve très vite
pour une nouvelle édition au revoir à
tous
[Musique]